There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
ELF has been killing it with
its new releases lately,
and we need to talk about
this new Power Grip Primer,
because it's excellent.
Immediately I compared it
to my Milk Hydro Grip Primer.
They are virtually identical
in terms of texture and how they apply,
except this ELF one is obviously cheaper.
Just like the Hydro Grip Primer,
it creates a really nice
tacky base for foundation
that's meant to make
your makeup last longer.
My foundation blended out
really nicely on top of this.
It wasn't pilling
or doing anything out of the ordinary.
I took some pictures
about five to six hours after I applied,
and I do think my makeup
lasted really well,
even my blush,
which is literally always the first thing
to disappear on my face.
ELF also released this powder foundation
in its Camo line.
I'll be honest: Powder foundations
are just not my thing.
I don't like how they look on my skin,
but the Camo line has
had nothing but hits,
so I had to try this.
The powder is so soft,
and it blends out very easily.
It definitely evened out my skin tone
and blurred some of those
areas I have of discoloration.
However, it just looks powdery!
I don't think it gives my skin
the most flattering texture.
I forgot to set it with some spray
to see if that helps at all,
but I don't see myself liking this,
even with setting spray
to melt it in a bit.
This is not for me.
I love trying new mascaras.
This is the Makeup Revolution
5D Lash Pow Mascara.
It's supposed to make it look like
you're wearing falsies.
The size of this brush is astronomical.
Oh, my God.
But I love a big
natural-bristle mascara brush.
Right away, I could tell
that this mascara was
doing a really nice job
of thickening my lashes.
And the more I built it up,
it gave my lashes this nice little curl.
I naturally have straight lashes,
and I hate curling them,
so I was really happy with the effect
this mascara gave them.
Also, I love how you push
the cap down to open it.
It's really satisfying to me.
The Fenty Beauty Killawatt
Freestyle Highlighter
is definitely not new,
but Madison Beer said she uses this one
in Ginger Binge/Moscow Mule as a blush,
and everyone bought it, including me.
Fenty highlighters are
more glittery than sheeny,
so I was a little nervous
about how this was going to look on me
and the texture on my cheeks.
It was definitely more metallic-looking,
because it's a highlighter
and not a blush,
but I actually did not hate this at all.
I did have to go over it with my sponge
to take away some of that glitter,
but the color and the glow
it brought to my cheeks
was super pretty.
I don't think you need
this specific product
for this kind of effect,
but if you're going to try it,
I recommend sticking to
the side with less glitter.
Charlotte Tilbury just dropped
this Beautiful Skin Foundation.
The claims on the box were so funny to me.
Like, "skin tone looks more
even by up to 210%" ...
sure.
This foundation had a
way thicker consistency
than I expected, and I
think because of that,
it didn't really melt into my skin
the way I wanted it to.
The coverage leaned more
on the lighter side,
so I went back into certain areas
and added some more.
It's definitely buildable,
but I'm not obsessed with
how my skin is looking.
I don't think it looks cakey,
it just looks like I'm wearing foundation,
and it's not as skin-like
as the name would have you think.
Do I think my skin tone looks more even
by up to 210%?
I can't really say,
but this is just OK to me.
I saw a TikTok that said
this Sigma Renew Lip Oil
is a possible dupe for
the $35 Dior lip oil,
so I had to compare the two,
because I am obsessed
with the Dior lip oil.
It feels so nourishing on the lips,
and it has that big doe-foot applicator
that feels so cushiony.
I could literally apply this all day.
The Sigma lip oil looks so much like it.
Look at these applicators.
They're almost identical.
The Sigma one is hydrating and shiny,
and it gives you that
moisturizing, non-sticky feeling.
It feels so much like the Dior one.
The only discernible difference
I found between the two
is that the Sigma one has no scent,
and the Dior one does.
It's $22, which is still
really pricey for a lip oil,
and it only comes in four shades,
but I think this is a really good dupe.
Highly recommend.
You guys have been asking me to try out
some Rare Beauty on this show,
so I picked up the new
Warm Wishes Effortless Bronzer Stick
and the Always an Optimist
Soft Radiance Setting Powder.
Let's talk about the bronzer stick first.
I immediately got nervous
swatching it on the back of my hand,
because it looked so red.
But I was so shocked
when I saw how easily it blended in.
I don't know why I applied this
like it was a contour stick,
but it worked out for me.
The texture of this is something special.
It's super smooth and soft and velvety,
and it doesn't blend into nothing.
You still see that color.
You still get the warmth of a bronzer.
It looked way less red
when I applied it to my face,
so I was actually really happy with this.
Now the setting powder.
I'll admit right now,
I made a mistake getting the medium shade.
I should've gone for light medium,
but I expected this to be way more sheer
than it actually was.
I normally use a translucent powder,
so using a setting powder with color
was new for me.
Applying it with my sponge
was an immediate no.
It made my skin look so patchy and weird.
My powder brush was
definitely the way to go.
The powder was super-finely milled,
and it gives your skin that soft blur
that looks really pretty.
It made my skin look a
lot smoother on the side
where I used my brush.
It's still a little
patchy in terms of color,
but that's obviously my fault,
because this is not my color.
I definitely need to try this again
in my appropriate shade.
And finally, let's talk about
the new NYX Thick It. Stick It! Brow Gel.
It's described as a
thickening brow mascara.
If you look really closely,
you can see those little fibers
that are supposed to make your brows
look fuller and fluffier.
I actually bought this for myself
and used it once and
thought it was just OK,
but I had no idea you
were supposed to layer it.
So I did that this time around,
and my brows came out so much better.
I'm obsessed with how
this right brow looks.
The left one, not so much,
but that's always my problem brow.
I kind of wish this had a smaller brush,
because I kept accidentally
spreading the product
outside of my brows.
But I do like the natural full effect
that you get with this.
I haven't tried a Hard Candy
product since I was a kid,
but this glitter palette
blew up on TikTok.
This is the Glitteratzi
glitter eye palette
in Glitz N' Cheer.
The glitter is not loose.
It does have some sort of sticky base
that holds it together
and makes it really easy to glide on.
I was honestly blown away
by how pigmented these glitters are.
I used my fingers to apply it to my eyes.
These top two shades do that thing where
depending on what angle your face is at,
the glitter disappears and reappears.
It's so magical and pretty.
I will say that I did get glitter fallout,
so I'd recommend using
another glitter base
to make sure that doesn't happen,
but I had fun playing
around with this palette.
If you're someone who's into glitter,
I highly recommend it.
Fenty Beauty just came out
with the Icon semi-matte
refillable lipstick.
So the case and the actual
lipstick are sold separately,
and then you assemble them together.
I'm not gonna lie, it took
me a minute to figure out,
but I did eventually.
I got the shade The MVP,
which is another universal red from Fenty
that's supposed to look
good on every skin tone.
The shape of the lipstick
was actually inspired
by Rihanna's iconic Cupid's bow,
and I actually found it really easy
to sort of map out my lip line with it,
since I didn't apply any lip liner before.
The pigment is incredible
and totally full coverage.
It's just a very creamy formula
that feels so smooth and
hydrating on the lips.
I can't even believe this is semi-matte.
It's definitely not transfer-proof,
but I was actually really impressed
by how it looked after I kissed my hand.
Clearly so much product came off,
but the lipstick still looked incredible.
It is interesting to see
regular lipstick releases
in the age of mask wearing,
but this formula is excellent.
NARS has a new foundation formula,
the Light Reflecting
Advanced Skincare foundation.
NARS knows how to do
complexion products so well,
and it has a huge hit with this.
I've actually been using
this for weeks now,
and I'm completely in love with it.
The foundation is so
lightweight on the skin.
It feels like you're not
even wearing foundation.
The coverage is on the
light to medium side,
but I definitely think you can build it up
without it getting cakey.
The finish is so nice.
It makes your skin look
really fresh and dewy
without looking oily,
and all of my other products layer
on top of this foundation really well.
KVD Beauty released its Good Apple
lightweight full-coverage concealer.
The name had me so intrigued,
because usually full-coverage products
can get heavy on the skin,
and my under-eyes are so picky
about what concealer they like.
I immediately love this applicator shape.
It picks up a good amount of product,
and the shape makes it easy to apply.
I could tell from testing it
out on the back of my hand
that it actually does
feel way more lightweight
than I expected, but
it covers really well.
I applied it everywhere I
normally apply concealer,
let it all sit for a second,
and then started blending.
This concealer blends like a dream.
It just melts into the skin
without losing any coverage.
I did add a little more
on my under-eye area
just for some extra brightening,
and it layered beautifully,
no problems there,
and then I set it all with the powder,
and I think it still looked really good
while feeling super-light on the face.
The name did not lie.
Colourpop released these adorable
heart-shaped pressed-powder blushes
just in time for Valentine's Day.
They kept selling out,
but I managed to get
this bright coral shade
called 4Ever Yours.
These blushes look
deceptively matte in the pan,
but if you look at my finger swatch,
it's definitely got a
pretty sheen, which I love.
This blush was so unbelievably pigmented.
I tapped my brush off before I applied it,
and it still went on this intensely.
But I went back in with a
clean brush to tone it down,
and it looked so much better.
This blush formula is
really silky and pretty,
plus a little goes a really
long way, so I love this.
Also, I am a sucker for
anything heart-shaped.
Karla Cosmetics is a
totally new brand for me,
and I've been dying to try its
Shadow Potion gel eye shadow.
It's this multichrome gel eye shadow.
I swatched it on my hand first,
and this texture isn't something
I've really tried before.
I just went in with my fingers
and did gentle tapping motions.
It does dry quickly, but not so quickly
that you don't have time to work with it.
It definitely showed up as
more pinky-purple on my eyes
with olive green on the outer corners.
That multichrome shift
depends on the lighting,
so I think it looked more obvious
away from direct sunlight.
Milk Makeup recently
released this Rise mascara.
I actually love their Kush mascara,
so I was really excited to try this,
and then I actually tried it.
This is just so average.
It took me three layers
for it to give my lashes any sort of lift,
and even that effect was subtle.
I've tried drugstore mascaras
that have done a lot more for a lot less.
This is the mini size,
and it was 14 bucks.
I will say I did love the packaging.
This material kind of
feels like a pencil grip,
and I love that.
The actual mascara, not so much.
This is the KimChi Chic
Beauty Teddy Kim palette
in the Boyfriend color story.
It's an eye-shadow and face palette.
I went in with the blush
and highlighter first,
and I loved them.
They were really buildable
and went on so smoothly.
Moving on to the eye shadow,
you do get a nice mix of mattes,
shimmers, and glitters.
I think all of these colors
work together really well.
I went in with a couple of mattes first,
and they blended great.
Then I played around with
these shimmers and glitters.
Again, these applied great.
They're super shiny and reflective,
but I did get fallout with the glitter,
so I recommend using a primer.
Overall, I was very
happy with this palette,
and another fun thing about it
is that it actually comes with stickers
so you can customize your little bear.
My bear definitely goes
to "Euphoria" high.
But, yes, I love this.
I can see this being
really good for travel,
although maybe a little bit hard to pack.
This is the ELF Cookies
'n Dreams lip gloss
in Cookie Dreams.
And, yes, it is a black lip gloss
with a bunch of pretty blue
and silver glitter throughout.
I tried this out on my bare lips first,
and I didn't love it
because you can see in the areas
where the gloss tends to pool a bit more,
it has this very obvious bluish-black tint
that looked a little odd on me.
But then I applied this
over my favorite lip liner,
and I immediately understood
why people liked this so much.
Oh, my God, it looked
incredible over lip liner.
It kind of gave the liner a deeper look
that just worked so well.
And the formula of the gloss itself
is actually really nice
for the $4 price point.
I'm definitely hanging on to this
to layer over other lip products.
The Rose Inc Skin Enhance
luminous tinted serum
is one of the weirdest products
I've seen in a while.
It's basically a skin tint
with this serum-y base
that's filled with pigment beads
that give you some coverage.
They say to apply this with a brush
to break up and spread
those pigment beads,
so that's what I did.
I really went into this thinking
it was just going to look
like an oily mess on me,
but then I noticed how good
it was making my skin look.
The coverage is light,
but it's just enough that it gives this
my-skin-naturally-looks-like-this-with-no-effort
kind of look.
I typically hide any
imperfections on my face
with a more full-coverage foundation,
but this made my skin
look so smooth and dewy
that I didn't feel like I needed more.
But this product really shocked me,
not only in how good it looked
but also in how good it made me feel.
I was so excited to try this
Huda Beauty Easy Bake loose baking
and setting powder in Cherry Blossom.
I had to get this baby version
because the full size
was completely sold out.
It's a baby pink setting powder
that's supposed to really
brighten up the under-eyes.
I just applied my concealer like normal
and went in with the little puff
that comes with it. This puff is nice,
but the shape was really annoying to use,
so I did use a brush
to get into the hard-to-reach spots.
This powder does have a
very strong floral scent
that was actually giving me a headache,
so I had to remove it after a few minutes.
It recommends that you
leave it on for five,
but I couldn't take it anymore. I'm sorry.
I did see a slight brightening effect,
but it wasn't blowing me away.
I could still see my dark circles
peeking through a bit. I do, however,
think that this is a nice powder formula.
It's really smoothing
and super-finely milled,
but they need to get rid of the scent.
Maybelline just dropped
its Super Stay Vinyl Ink
Longwear No-Budge Liquid Lipcolor.
This is a long-wearing lipstick
that's meant to stay shiny,
which really got my attention.
You have to shake it for
five seconds, then apply.
When I first started applying,
I got nervous because
it looked really patchy,
but I got full coverage
when I added another layer,
and it surprisingly felt
lightweight on the lips.
I kissed my hand to check for transfer,
and there definitely was some.
I did a test wearing my mask
and saw some transfer there too.
And then I took a sip of my drink
and saw minimal transfer there as well.
Even though I was
getting a little transfer
and most of the shine was gone,
the lipstick itself
still looked super bright
and it didn't move anywhere,
so I was happy with that.
This is the Dior Backstage
Flash Perfector concealer.
I think the main thing
that's special about this
is that it has a brush applicator
instead of a doe-foot applicator,
so that's supposed to
be easier to blend in.
I still had to use my sponge for blending,
but I did like how easy
application was with the brush,
although I wouldn't say it was any easier
than a regular doe-foot applicator.
The formula itself is really nice.
The coverage is more on the medium side,
but it covered enough.
I like this concealer,
but I wouldn't tell you
to go run and get it.
It's just a nice concealer
with a high-end name on it.
The Beauty Blender Power Pocket Puff
is basically a double-sided velour puff.
So the pink side is
for powder application,
and the tan side is for
blending the powder and makeup.
It does pick up a lot of product.
I tried to tap off as much as I could,
but it still deposited a lot of powder.
It is described as a tool you can use
for baking the under-eye area,
so maybe that's why.
The shape does make it easy to use,
and I liked how it has
this little strap on it
that can be used on either side.
After leaving the powder on for a bit,
I used the tan side to blend it in,
and it wasn't getting
rid of all the powder,
so I did use a brush
to dust off the excess.
I noticed that my under-eye area
looked really smooth, smoother than when
I set the area with my normal sponge.
The lines under my eyes
weren't as defined.
This is the new MAC MACStack mascara,
and it's supposed to be super volumizing,
which I love. What I don't love
is a plastic mascara
brush, which this has,
but I was still excited to try this.
When I first started applying,
I immediately hated the
feeling of the brush on my eye.
It's a little too spiky
for someone like me
with pretty sensitive eyes.
I noticed an instant lift
and volume with my lashes,
which are naturally pretty straight.
I did another coat and loved
how this made my lashes look.
They look long and full
without looking clumpy.
I don't know if I can
justify $28 for mascara,
but this one is so good.
I might have to splurge
on it every now and then.
We have two new face products
from One/Size Beauty,
the Cheek Clapper 3D blush trio palette
and the Made for Shade
bronze and sculpt trio.
Let's get into the sculpt palette first.
I used a mix of the bottom two shades,
and they brought some
much-needed warmth for my face.
They blend really nicely and smoothly.
These are nice bronzers,
but I think the real star of the show here
is the blush palette.
If I had to pick one of these two palettes
to splurge on, it would
definitely be this one.
These are three different formulas,
a flex cream, a full-impact
matte,
and a hyper sheen.
I went in with a very light hand
because these are really pigmented,
and they just look really beautiful
and smooth on the skin.
The color can be built up or toned down
as much as you want,
which I think is my favorite
thing about this palette.
There are just so many
different ways you can use it,
and all the formulas
work so nicely together.
Rare Beauty just released the
Positive Light tinted
moisturizer with SPF 20.
I was so happy that this had SPF in it.
The formula felt thicker
and looked more full-coverage
than I expected.
Also, this was a shade
or two too light for me,
so ignore that.
It does sheer out as you apply it,
so it looks less like a foundation
and more like a tinted moisturizer.
I applied the rest of
my powder makeup on top
and honestly wasn't loving how it looked.
I felt like it kept building up
in the dry patches around my nose
and just looked a little too textured.
But then I redid my makeup
with all cream products
on top of this tinted moisturizer,
and it looked so much better,
just super dewy and fresh.
So I much preferred using
it with cream products.
This is the NYX Wonder
Stick cream blush contour,
and it's literally a blush stick
that you use to contour your face.
There's a lighter shade
that's meant to be used as a blush
and a deeper shade that you contour with.
I have never contoured with blush,
so I was really intrigued by this.
I applied the darker shade
wherever I would normally contour
and the lighter shade above it
and then blended it out.
This isn't the easiest formula to blend,
but I eventually got
it looking pretty good.
I didn't hate the blush-contour look.
I just think this blush
formula isn't great,
and I've definitely tried
better at the drugstore.
I haven't experimented
much with correctors,
but I saw a TikTok recommending this one,
the Benefit Boi-ing Bright On
brightening undereye concealer.
It has this peachy color
to counteract the darkness
underneath the eyes.
I tested it out before applying makeup,
and I could see a difference already.
So then I applied a small
amount, blended that,
then applied concealer on top,
and I think it did make a difference.
My under-eyes looked brighter than usual.
I definitely noticed less darkness
than when I just use concealer,
and the product didn't do anything weird
to the concealer I applied on top.
It didn't make it patchy or bunch up,
so I'm actually really into this.
I realized later you're just supposed
to wear this on its own,
which I clearly did not do.
But I was still happy with the results.
Charlotte Tilbury came out
with a new Pillow Talk collection
inspired by its popular
lipstick in Pillow Talk,
so I picked up a few of the products.
I already love the Beauty Light Wands,
so I knew that I would love
this Pillow Talk shade.
It's super glowy and makes
the skin look so beautiful.
The Multi-Glow highlighter
was a new product for me.
The packaging is so pretty.
I didn't even want to touch it, but I did.
It has this almost soft blurring effect
that looks really nice.
And it's not glittery at all,
just like a soft glow.
The product I was most excited to try
was actually the mascara
in the shade Dream Pop.
It's described as a berry-brown shade.
I don't think I have ever tried
a colored mascara before,
but I applied it like I normally would,
and I actually love the color.
The formula isn't my favorite,
and neither is the brush,
but I think the color
was actually flattering on my eyes.
It's supposed to bring out
the amber in brown eyes.
I don't know if that's what's happening,
but it did make my eyes look
really sparkly, which I love.
I saw that Flower Beauty had this
Spotlight liquid highlighter
that looked a lot like
the Charlotte Tilbury
Light Wand in the Pillow Talk shade,
so I really wanted to compare the two
to see if it was a dupe.
The shades aren't exactly the same,
but they're super close.
Both are so easy to blend out
and look more natural and dewy on the skin
than a powder highlight does.
I think the Charlotte Tilbury one
is a bit more reflective
than the Flower Beauty one,
but the effect is definitely similar.
The Flower Beauty one looks
just as beautiful on the skin,
and it's almost $30 cheaper.
So I highly recommend this if you haven't
gotten the chance to try the Light Wands.
I'm an East Coast girl,
so I was so excited when I saw
that ELF collabed with Dunkin'.
This was such a fun, cute idea.
This huge doughnut
sponge was so ridiculous,
I had to try it out.
It's big even before wetting,
and it was pretty hard at first.
But it doubled in size once I wet it,
and it became a lot softer and squishier.
I'm not gonna lie,
applying foundation with
this is kind of great
because it's so big.
It literally applies
foundation in five seconds.
I decided to use it to
apply all my other makeup,
and the size does get more
difficult to work with
the more precise you're trying to be.
You can see that I was accidentally
spreading my blush up way too high.
But I think overall, the
makeup came out looking good.
Obviously, this is more like a novelty
than a super-useful makeup tool,
but it comes in handy if you
want to apply makeup quickly.
I also ordered the Glazed
for Days lip gloss set
because I cannot resist an orange gloss,
let alone an orange gloss
that smells like glazed doughnuts.
This is a really nice gloss.
The color is pretty sheer,
but for the price point,
I think this formula is super glossy
and comfortable on the lips.
Donni Davy, the head makeup
artist of "Euphoria,"
just came out with her own
makeup line, Half Magic,
and I bought a bunch of
products to test out.
First up, we have these
Chromaddiction matte eye paints.
They have a lot of pigment
and were really easy to layer and blend.
They don't dry down too fast,
and you can use them as eyeliner,
which is what I did.
They have this reusable
wing guide, which was OK.
I feel like it was a little too flimsy,
so I didn't get that
great of a wing with this.
This Glitterpill was so pretty,
and the applicator made it so easy to use.
Plus, you don't have
to use a glitter base.
It just dries down and stays put.
The Light Trap glow powders
definitely do give you a nice glow,
and you can use them anywhere on the face.
Like, I put this purple one on my eyes,
and it looked so cool.
Of course, I also had
to get these iridescent
face gems, which are self-adhering,
so you don't need any
glue for the first use.
You will need glue if you reuse them.
These are so easy to apply
and add such a cute sparkle.
The last product I got was
the Magic Brownie Liptrik Kit.
It has a darker and lighter lip liner,
so you can customize the lipstick.
The lip liner is very smooth and creamy,
and this lipstick is super
comfortable on the lips.
This brand as a whole really inspires you
to play with your makeup, which I love,
and I really liked the
products that I tried.
I'm excited to see what
they come out with next.
Danessa Myricks Beauty just released
this Skin Blurring Balm Powder.
I got the universal shade,
which is translucent,
and I also got the shade 4.
So, you can use this as a primer,
concealer and contour, a foundation,
or it can be used to set your foundation.
I first tried the
universal one as a primer
under my go-to foundation.
The texture is kind of strange.
It blends in easily like a balm would,
but it dries down to, like,
a soft-matte powder finish.
It really does blur a
lot of imperfections.
My foundation went over this so smoothly,
and it did make it slightly more matte
than it usually looks, but I didn't mind.
Then I tried the tinted
shade just as a foundation.
It did take me a while to blend out,
but once I did, I really liked the finish.
This is actually more full
coverage than I was expecting.
I feel like it covered a lot!
I did end up wearing
this for the entire day,
and I noticed that I was much less oily
at the end of the day than usual.
It does have a bit of a learning curve,
but once you figure out
how to make this work
for your skin, it's a really cool product.
I don't know why it's taken me this long
to try the About-Face
Matte Fluid Eye Paints,
but I'm finally doing it.
These are liquid eye colors that come in
full-coverage mattes or sheer shades.
Don't be scared by that orange swatch.
That one is a sheer shade.
The pigment in these is incredible.
They're super easy to
apply and to blend out.
You can build up the color if you want,
and it still feels lightweight.
Plus, I'm in love with this packaging.
These are amazing, and I need more colors.
The Espressoh Glassy blush is one of those
pH-reactive products.
It goes from clear to a
pink tint on the skin.
I first tried it over my foundation,
and it started to break down
the product I already had on.
It was pilling so much.
So we were off to a bad start.
I tried it out on my bare skin,
and it worked a lot better.
It's cute and a fun idea,
but I'm not blown away by this.
I would rather just get a blush
that works on skin and over makeup.
This is the Bdellium large
rounded double dome blender,
and it looks like a little mouth.
It's basically like two brushes in one.
It's supposed to blend
in product really fast
and give you an airbrushed finish.
You can use it with any liquid,
cream, or powder product,
so I decided I would do a full face
with just this brush.
I was immediately blown
away by how quickly
and seamlessly this
blended in the product.
Plus, this was, like, the
softest brush I've ever felt.
You're supposed to do these
back-and-forth motions,
and I thought it would look so streaky,
but it just looked really
smooth and well blended.
Because of the size, it is
a little difficult to use
for the more precise
products, like concealer,
but they do sell smaller
sizes of this brush.
I loved it.
This is the Saie Hydrabeam brightening
and hydrating under-eye concealer.
It has a radiant finish,
which had me a little worried.
I don't really think "radiant"
when I'm picking out a concealer.
The coverage is light, a
little too light for my taste.
I'm a medium- to full-coverage girl
when it comes to concealer,
but the finish is pretty and skin-like.
It also looked good when
I set it with powder,
but I absolutely hate
the applicator on this.
In my opinion, it's too short.
It is so stiff, and it
doesn't do a great job
of picking up and spreading
the product around.
Other than that, this is a
very nice everyday concealer.
These are the Tarte
Maracuja Juicy Lip Plumps,
and they're supposed to give
you a tingle-free plumping.
They actually are so juicy.
Look at how shiny that is.
My first reaction to these was that
they are incredibly fragile.
Like, you want to be careful with how much
pressure you're using,
because it will break.
So I didn't love that.
But these feel so good on the lips.
Like, I could not stop
rubbing them together.
It's so comfortable and hydrating.
The plumping was actually
tingle-free for me.
It just felt minty, like I
rubbed toothpaste on my lips.
The plumping effect is subtle,
but I still really liked these.
I did it.
I bought the Jones Road
Beauty What the Foundation.
This has caused all kinds of
controversy and discourse,
so I apologize for also
putting in my 2 cents.
This is what it looks like.
It's very oily and thick.
It has a scent I actually don't mind.
It's like a soft, spa-like smell.
I applied a pretty small
amount for me with my fingers
and then went over that with my sponge,
and I did not hate how this looked.
It's very skin-like.
It felt like I wasn't
even wearing foundation.
I will say it tends to
gather in certain areas,
so I might have to go in
with even less product.
My other products layered
on top of this fine,
but I feel like I like this more
as an everyday skin tint
rather than a foundation
base for my makeup.
Like, I would reach for this
when I'm running errands
on a Sunday morning,
but not when I'm going to the club.
I've been obsessed with lip oil,
so I immediately snapped up
this Fenty Beauty Cherry Treat
conditioning and strengthening lip oil.
I have to start off by saying
this is the most
amazing-smelling lip product.
It smells like cherry candies.
We got this giant doe-foot
applicator I love.
I did not want to stop applying this.
It felt so nice.
This formula makes your lips feel
so hydrated and soft and cushiony,
if that makes any sense.
It's also so glossy.
The color is so sheer
it doesn't really look
like much on my lips,
but I love this,
and it's definitely going in my bag.
I also got the Fenty Beauty
Poutsicle hydrating lip stain.
This also feels so good on the lips.
Every lip stain I've tried
has been more drying, not hydrating,
so I am really into this formula.
It's very pigmented,
so I was careful when I was applying
to make sure I didn't
get the stain anywhere
outside of my lips.
After leaving it on for a few minutes,
I wiped it off with a paper towel,
and there was definitely
a pretty stain left behind
that was 100% transfer-proof.
I can see myself wearing
this a lot this summer.
If you can believe it,
I have never tried a
Haus Labs product before.
They recently rebranded,
and I picked up a couple of products.
First up, this Haus Labs
Hy-Power pigment paint.
You can use this anywhere on the face.
The pigment in these
actually took me by surprise.
Like, I was not expecting
them to be so full-coverage.
You need the tiniest amount of these.
It blended out pretty easily on my eyes,
and it doesn't dry too quickly,
so you have some time to work.
I am so into these.
I also picked up the PhD hybrid lip oil.
This applicator is much
smaller than the Fenty one,
which made me sad,
but the actual formula is really smooth
and comfortable on the lips.
It's more of a thinner formula
than other lip oils I've tried,
but I really loved how
this looked and felt.
This also has no scent,
which I prefer over a bad scent.
These were great products,
and I need to try more.
Uoma Beauty just released
this Trippin smooth powder,
and what's so cool about it
is how the powder dispenses.
You twist it,
and it releases the
perfect amount of powder,
which I love because my
powders get so messy.
The powder itself is so finely
milled and silky smooth.
It applied really nicely
and smoothed out my under-eyes a bit,
so I really liked it.
I've been on the hunt for
a good talc-free powder,
and I think this is it.
The only thing I wish they had
was a translucent option,
but this is so good.
I tried two products
from Makeup Revolution.
Let's start with this
Blush Bomb cream blusher.
This straight up looks and
feels like a lip gloss.
It was very confusing.
It's definitely more of
an oily blush formula
than I'm used to.
First application wasn't great.
It's pretty sheer, but it does build up.
I don't think I like this, though.
I think it just feels like
lip gloss on my cheeks.
I also tried the Superfix misting spray.
I know I just complained
about the blush looking like a lip gloss,
but I love that this
looks like a hair spray.
The mist is nice,
but I wish it was a continuous mist.
I applied this underneath my makeup
and then on top when I was finished.
That's how I like to use setting spray.
It melted the makeup in nicely,
but I typically like a more dewy finish,
and this is pretty matte.
I wore this makeup for eight hours,
and I think I looked OK
at the end of the day.
I feel like I could still see my blush,
which is usually the
first thing to disappear.
This isn't my favorite setting spray,
but I do think it's a good cheaper option.
Pat McGrath released a new shade
of her Skin Fetish
highlighter and balm duo.
This has a balm on one side
and this really beautiful
highlighter on the other.
This shade, Xtreme Cyber
Orchid, is so interesting.
It shifts from a blue to a lilac
and totally disappears at certain angles.
This formula is definitely balmy,
but not in an oily way.
I got so nervous when I first applied it,
because this was not blending in at all,
but it blended in really nicely
when I used my fingers.
I think for 58 bucks I would rather get
a more wearable everyday shade,
but this formula is really nice.
This is the Maybelline Tattoo
Studio brow-lift stick,
which is supposed to give you a brow lift
or a brow-lamination effect at home.
It has a cool little brush on one side
and then this colored wax on the other.
So you brush your brows up first,
apply the wax to fill in,
and then use the brush
to lift the brow hairs.
This is a cool idea,
and I did like how it made my brows look,
but it did take a bit of work.
I think if this brush had firmer bristles,
it would be easier to get
that brow-lift effect.
I also just don't think
this wax is waxy enough
to hold my brows up all
day, so this was just OK.
I'm a big fan of the Made
by Mitchell Blurshes.
I tried a purple blush from them before,
and I loved it, and they just came out
with a lavender shade, so I had to try it.
Applying it on top of
my makeup was a mistake,
because it's a pastel.
It was basically like
I applied a white blush
over my bronzer.
Plus, it actually made
my foundation patchy,
which is an issue that I've
never had with this formula.
I think I might've just overblended.
Trying it out on bare
skin wasn't any better.
It just leaves this
very gray-looking cast.
I looked like the Corpse Bride.
I think I'm better off using this
as an eyeliner and eye-shadow base.
Clinique has finally come
out with a lip-gloss version
of its iconic Black Honey lipstick.
This color is definitely identical
to the lipstick version, just glossy.
Here's what they look like side by side.
I liked it a little more
once I dabbed some off.
This color is just really flattering.
I have to say, though, this gloss formula
is not my favorite.
I think they were going
for a cushiony feel,
but it's just kind of sticky and thick.
Looks great, but it doesn't feel so great.
ELF released this Halo Glow Liquid Filter,
and the world stopped.
Could this actually be a dupe
for the Charlotte Tilbury
Flawless Filter? Let's see.
On this side of my face I
applied Flawless Filter.
It's gorgeous. It's glowy. It's perfect.
Now, on this side, I
applied the ELF Halo Glow.
Look at them side by side.
They are almost identical.
I would say that the ELF one
has a hint more coverage,
but it still gives that same
your-skin-but-better effect.
And the Charlotte Tilbury
one is slightly more glowy.
Slightly.
I say save yourself the extra 30 bucks
and get the ELF one.
Side note: Look at the
size of this doe foot.
It's huge!
You guys know I adore Rare Beauty.
I was so excited when they dropped
these Kind Words matte
lipsticks and lip liners.
I had to get the color Gifted,
because Selena said that
that was her favorite.
The lip liner is supersmooth.
Even though it's matte,
it doesn't drag or pull on the lips.
Plus, it's a twist-up, which I love.
The lipstick is so creamy and pigmented.
You could probably put
this on in one swipe.
It's definitely one of
the most comfortable
matte lipsticks I've ever tried.
Scrandie Beauty is a
brand I found on TikTok.
I kept seeing videos of its
Spicy Sauce lip plumper,
and I really wanted to test it out,
since I haven't had much
luck with lip plumpers.
I applied it to half my lips,
so we could see if it
actually does anything.
So, you apply it slightly
above your lip line,
and it starts to feel a little spicy,
then it starts to feel tingly and spicy,
and then at the three-minute mark,
you also start to feel
a warming sensation.
I love lip plumpers,
so I don't mind the roller
coaster this takes you on.
It feels kind of good to me.
I definitely notice plumping,
especially with my top lip.
I really like this lip plumper,
and I also like that it's clear,
so you can wear it on top of anything.
Eco Styler is the brand
of gel I use all the time,
and I never knew it had
this Unicorn Glitter Gel.
It's a translucent pink color
with blue iridescent sparkles.
It's so pretty.
Running this through my hair,
I feel like you don't really
get the glittery effect.
It just kind of tinted my
hair this bluish color,
which is cool,
just not what I thought
it was going to look like.
I definitely saw the
glitter and color better
when I applied it to
brushed-back straight hair.
I think this is cute for
a little glitter moment
every once in a while.
And it actually washed
out of my hair easily.
I don't know if you guys know this,
but I'm a nail-polish freak.
So when I saw Dew by Jinsoon going viral,
I bought it immediately.
This is a milky-white polish.
It's very sheer and soft.
My nails are super stained right now,
so I was worried about how it was looking
after the first coat,
but when I went in with that second coat,
it looked really pretty,
and my nails looked so much better.
It was a little streaky in the first coat,
but the second went on totally smooth.
I do wish, though, that
this had a flat paddle brush
instead of this brush just
to make it easier to paint.
I'm sure you could find a really good
drugstore dupe for this polish,
because it is on the pricey side,
but I really like it.
This is the new Urban Decay Vice Lip Bond
glossy liquid lipstick.
So you get the glossiness of a lip gloss
and the wear of a liquid lipstick.
This is extremely pigmented.
I was really impressed by the color,
but I feel like it wasn't as shiny
as I thought it would be.
I let it dry down for 10 minutes
and kissed the back of my hand
to see if it transferred at all,
and it did, but only a little bit,
and the lipstick still looked good.
It's actually very
similar to the Maybelline
Vinyl Ink lip color I tried a while ago,
so I would probably recommend that one,
since it's cheaper and performs the same.
I am not a pot-concealer kind of person,
but I was really excited to try out
this REM Beauty Sweetener concealer.
I also got the Dreamcloud
blender to test out as well.
I scooped some up and just warmed it
on the back of my hand.
Then I used my fingers
to apply everywhere I wanted to conceal.
The concealer looks thicker than it feels.
I was actually surprised
at how lightweight it felt
when I was blending it out.
The coverage with this is amazing.
I was so shocked at
how much it covered up.
You don't need a lot at all.
I definitely put too much on,
but I really, really like this.
They also included a black and white shade
in this concealer, so you
can lighten your shade
or deepen it, which is cool.
I also really like this little sponge,
but it's not worth $15.
These NYX Ultimate Glow
Shots look so pretty
that I literally bought three of them.
They're supposed to be brightening
and give a really glowy effect.
Although these are gorgeous in the tube,
they're just really
inconsistent on the eyes.
The pigment on some is better than others,
but overall, I would say the pigment
isn't great with these on their own.
I had to build them up a lot
to get them to look like this.
They definitely work better as a topper
over other eye shadows.
I'm so torn on these
because they look so good,
but it takes a lot of
work to get them that way.
I've been seeing these
gorgeous holo glosses
from Queen Cosmetics all over TikTok.
Of course, I had to get three of them.
These glosses are just
as beautiful in person.
They honestly feel fine on the lips,
as long as you don't apply too much.
I packed on this Electric shade,
and it did feel a little gritty,
so I recommend only doing
one to two thin layers
to avoid that, but these are so cool.
They look good on their own
but even better over lipstick,
especially darker colors.
This is the new Fenty Beauty Eaze Drop'Lit
All-Over Glow Enhancer.
It can be worn on its own
to reduce the look of pores
or mixed into foundation
for some added glow.
Using this on its own,
I honestly wasn't very impressed.
I don't think my pores
were necessarily blurred,
and I felt like my skin
didn't look that glowy.
It kind of just looked
like I applied moisturizer.
I think this worked better
when mixed into a foundation.
I mixed it with my Eaze
Drop Blurring Skin Tint,
which I love, and I
noticed it gave my skin
a nice little glow.
This skin tint is more on the matte side,
so I do like that the glow
enhancer made it more dewy.
However, I don't think
it's such a big difference
that I can justify buying this product.
It kind of just feels like an extra step
that doesn't add much.
Item Beauty is Addison Rae's beauty brand.
People rave about its lip oils,
so I figured I'd test it out
with a couple of other products too.
So, this is the Lip Quip
moisturizing lip oil.
Let me start out by
saying it smells amazing,
kind of peachy.
The color was actually
a little more pigmented
than I expected for a lip oil,
but I thought it was so pretty.
The formula is on the thicker side.
It feels super nourishing
and just makes your lips look so juicy,
so I am really into this.
This is going in my bag.
Next I tried the Boost
Juice dual-ended lash primer
and colored mascara.
So you can use this as a lash
primer or colored mascara.
The lilac side is for volume,
and the blue side is for lengthening.
I have to admit I much
preferred the blue side
as just a colored mascara.
I feel like once I applied
regular mascara on top of it,
my lashes just kind of lumped together.
The lilac side barely
showed up on my lashes,
but it worked much
better as a lash primer.
I also tried the Blushin Like cream blush.
It's supposed to be a
cream-to-powder formula,
but it just kind of feels like a powder.
I used my sponge to apply it at first,
but it just kind of
looked a little splotchy.
It worked much better with a brush.
You can also apply it to the lips,
and it was honestly cute.
It's buildable, which I like,
but I don't feel like
this is anything special.
ColourPop drops new stuff,
like, every other day,
but these Graphix ink
liners caught my eye.
I really like this tip. I's
supersharp and flexible.
I am horrible at doing any
kind of liner situation,
so I was really glad
that this tip kind of did the work for me.
However, the color payoff
on these is not great.
I found myself layering up the product
for full color payoff,
and with this formula,
the more you layer, the
more textured it looks.
It sucks because these are colors
that I don't really see
a lot of in eyeliner,
but this formula is just not my favorite.
IT Cosmetics just dropped another
Love is the Foundation brush.
I think it drops one of these a year.
I have one from a previous
year that I really love,
but they're actually not the same.
This new one is less dense
and more flexible than my old one,
and I also feel like the bristles
on this new one are longer.
I used it to apply my foundation,
and I was really happy with how fast
it blended everything in
without looking streaky.
It also worked great with my concealer.
I didn't lose any coverage with this brush
because it didn't absorb the product.
I think I actually like this new one
better than my old one.
I tried a couple of
products from J.Cat Beauty.
Let's talk about this blush first.
This color is so pretty.
It's like an orangey pink
with a bunch of gold shimmer in it,
so you get this very buildable color
with some added glow.
I can definitely see this color working
for so many different skin tones.
The Mood Flick holo-sparkle lip balm
is one of those
color-changing lip products.
I honestly thought these
would be more glittery,
but I think it just looked metallic on me.
They do actually feel pretty
moisturizing on the lips.
I was really surprised
at how much these stain.
When I was trying to take it off,
my lips were bright pink.
I don't know if I'd ever use these again,
but they're cute.
I haven't reviewed a Too
Faced product in forever,
but it just released this
Born This Way Ethereal
Light smoothing concealer,
and I heard really good things about it.
It's supposed to be super
hydrating and smoothing.
I did not like the applicator on this,
not because of the shape,
but because it doesn't
pick up product that well.
This formula is actually really nice.
Even after blending it out
and setting it with powder,
you can still see that
luminosity in the concealer.
I don't know if it did much smoothing,
but I like the coverage it gave me
and how easy it was to work with.
This is the Dior Rouge Dior Forever
transfer-proof lipstick.
Not a liquid lipstick, a regular lipstick.
So you apply this like any other lipstick,
wait three minutes for the color to set,
and you should be left
with a long-wearing, transfer-proof lip.
I think this particular
shade was a bit patchy,
but I evened it out as much as I could.
I could not believe how well this worked.
I was expecting a lot of transfer
because this is a regular lipstick,
but the transfer was pretty minimal.
It also didn't feel
too drying on the lips.
I think this formula is really cool,
and I want to try out some other shades.
I finally got my hands on
the Haus Labs Atomic Shake lip lacquer.
This is another one of
those transfer-proof
glossy lipsticks.
This is definitely the
hot new lip formula.
So, you shake the product
well, then apply it.
The pigment in this really shocked me.
It was so vibrant, it almost looked neon.
This went on so smooth,
I didn't need more than one
layer for full coverage,
and it was so glossy.
I had to wait 15 seconds
for what they call the
"shine shield" to form.
Then I kissed the back of my hand
to see if I got any transfer, and nothing.
I've tried three lipsticks
with this kind of formula,
and so far, this is the best one.
This is the Modelones Color
Cube in Bonfire Amour.
It's a solid gel cream palette.
It comes with nine gel polishes,
and you can get them in
different color stories
and finishes.
It also comes with this little brush.
I've used a solid gel cream before,
but I forgot how thick it actually is,
so it did take me some time
to apply it in even layers.
I did have to do two coats
for full coverage on some colors.
I think a product like this
can be super convenient,
especially if you do nail art
or just don't have the space
to keep a bunch of gel polishes around.
It doesn't come with a base or topcoat,
but I still really like this.
I tested out a ton of
products from Jason Wu Beauty.
This is a new brand for me,
so let's start with what I didn't like.
This Free-Da Brow was too light
for me, which is my fault,
but the formula on this is weird.
It feels like an oily cream
that never dries down,
so I doubt it'll keep my brows in place.
These Stay in Line lip
liners weren't great.
They were also too light for me,
so I ended up using my own
lip liner to deepen it.
These are smooth but a little too creamy.
They don't feel like they're going to
last very long on the lips at all.
I also didn't like the Wu-Prime Eye.
The formula is so tacky and thick.
It made my eye shadow look
patchy in certain areas.
Now on to the stuff I loved.
This Flora 4 palette was
surprisingly pigmented
and easy to blend.
I feel like the primer
is what got in the way
of showing you its full potential,
but I still really liked it.
This blush trio is so gorgeous
and blended out really nicely.
I used this Ready to Shimmer
cream shadow as a highlighter,
and it gave me the prettiest golden glow,
even though it's not
really meant for the face.
This Jewel Stick was incredible.
Look how much it brightened
up my inner corners.
The Honey Fluff lip cream
was soft and comfortable on the lips.
If you get anything from this brand,
get this Extra Pout lip plumper.
Oh, my God. Even if you don't care
about the lip-plumping aspect,
this is one of the best lip-gloss formulas
I have ever tried.
It's so cushiony and shiny and amazing,
and everyone should get it.
The Make Up For Ever The
Professionall Mascara
is ... definitely a mascara.
It's nothing amazing.
It has one side for lifting
and the other side for volumizing.
I didn't get much of a lift,
but I did get a nice amount of volume.
I just think there are
better mascaras out there
for way less money.
I am a huge fan of About-Face.
I love so many of its products.
So when these Cheek Freak
blush balms dropped,
I snatched up three different colors.
I'm just gonna say it.
I am so in love with these.
I was nervous at first
because it's described as a "blush balm,"
which to me sounded like it
would break up my foundation,
but these blended in so beautifully.
It never moved the product underneath,
even if my skin was already powdered,
and the pigment on these is unreal.
You can build them up
however much you want.
I think these can work for
so many different skin tones.
They are so, so good.
I made the horrible mistake of purchasing
the Winky Lux Saucy Gloss
four-piece combo lip-gloss set.
This was made in
collaboration with Applebee's,
and the glosses are
inspired by its wing sauces.
You guys, I thought
everyone was exaggerating
when they said the smell
was making them gag, but no.
These smell God-awful, and it sucks so bad
because the color story is so pretty.
And I could see this concept working
had they just not added the sauce scents,
or even if they did something like,
lemon pepper smells like lemon,
Buffalo is just a spicy lip plumper.
But no, they went in this direction.
We all bought it and talked about it,
which is probably what they wanted.
So I hope you're happy, Winky Lux.
You ruined four beautiful glosses.
I tried out a new foundation from Chanel.
I actually wouldn't
call this a foundation.
It's more like a
super-hydrating, light tint.
It's very similar to that
Rose Inc tinted serum
I tried a while ago.
So it has these pigment beads that burst
and spread as you apply it.
This literally feels
like nothing on the skin.
There is little coverage,
but it evens everything out
nicely and it feels hydrating.
I don't think this has
a strong staying power,
but it's still a pretty tint
for when you don't want to do too much.
Chanel also has a blush in this formula,
so I tested that out too.
I actually blended it out
on the back of my hand
before applying and tapped
it on with a sponge.
It took a minute to build up the color,
but I think it's supposed
to look very natural.
It also didn't break up
the product underneath.
I'm surprised by how much I liked these.
They don't do too much,
but it's enough to make a difference.
This is the Maybelline Shadow
Blocks Eyeshadow Palette.
It's a tiny stack of eye shadows,
very similar to the Kaja bento trios.
The packaging is pretty cheap.
One of my shadows fell out, but it's OK.
I applied these without any primer
just to see how they perform on their own.
They're actually pretty pigmented shadows.
I didn't have any trouble blending them,
and the shimmer shade was pretty,
but overall I think these are just OK.
I like the idea of a palette like this
more than the execution.
Everyone has been loving
these NYX Jumbo Lash lashes,
so I had to try them
even though I am terrible
with false lashes.
I thought the style Ego Flare
would look nice on my eye
shape, and I was right.
These lashes made me feel
like a whole new person.
Like, these are Disney princess eyes.
They were pretty easy to apply,
and the band was really comfortable.
I think these have totally convinced me
to wear lashes more often.
This is the Urban Decay
24/7 Moondust Shadow
in Space Cowboy.
This is basically a glitter shadow.
This shade in particular
has been going viral.
It is super intense and reflective,
but you can definitely
diffuse it to be more subtle.
This formula is really
smooth and easy to work with
however you want to use
it, so I really loved this.
I did get some glitter fallout,
so I'd recommend using a primer
or leaving some powder under
the eyes while you're applying.
If you want something more eye-catching
and elevated than a shimmer
shadow, this is perfect.
Em Cosmetics re-released
its Color Drops Serum Blush
with a new-and-improved
formula and packaging.
The old packaging was
notoriously difficult to use.
It had this dropper thing
that just would not dispense properly.
This new dropper is so much better.
You do have to build this blush up,
but it gives you a really
pretty, dewy flush of color.
I honestly can't see a difference
between the old formula and the new one,
this new one is just easier to use.
I'm not super into this
kind of blush formula.
I prefer the brand's powder
or cream blush over this.
But it's pretty, and it
didn't break up my foundation.
I've been dying to test out
the new Haus Labs foundation,
I've heard nothing but amazing things,
and I was not disappointed.
I went in with my foundation brush first,
and this just totally blends
into the skin seamlessly.
The coverage is on the lighter side,
so I added a little more,
and I am really impressed
by how weightless it is.
It has skincare ingredients in it,
and it actually feels like skincare.
It feels like you have
absolutely nothing on your face.
All of my other products
blended on top of this beautifully.
So this foundation is
a 10 out of 10 for me.
I also got the Bio-Blurring
Loose Setting Powder,
and I love this too.
It definitely does blur the
skin and sets your makeup
without making it look dry or cakey.
It's so soft and finely milled,
and it's also talc-free, which is great.
I tried a couple lip
products from Fenty Beauty,
the Gloss Bomb Heat Universal
Lip Luminizer and Plumper
in Hot Chocolit Heat
and the Gloss Bomb Ice
Cooling Lip Luminizer
in Cold Heart'd.
Let's talk about this
new Gloss Bomb Ice first.
It looks like a pale blue color,
but it goes on totally clear.
It has a really nice minty scent.
You get that cooling effect
instantly, and I like it.
It also feels great on the lips,
like the other Fenty glosses,
just super hydrating and shiny.
The Gloss Bomb Heat is not a new formula,
but people have been loving
the Hot Chocolit Heat shade.
It's like a brown with a
hint of rosiness to it.
Because it's on the more sheer side,
this color looks incredible
on so many different skin tones,
and it actually does plump
the lips really nicely.
It's not an uncomfortable
plumping effect at all.
A few of you asked if I could
review Mooncat polishes,
so I have a few to talk about.
This first one is called Illusionist,
and it's a magnetic multichrome.
I feel like Mooncat always has
these really interesting colors like this
that I don't see very often.
The magnetic effect on
this one is so cool.
I couldn't stop staring at my nails.
This next shade is called Cyclone,
and it's a blue-jelly flaky polish.
The way these iridescent
flakes look in this jelly
really give you this ocean vibe,
so I loved this one too.
The last polish I tried was Emo for Life,
which is just a plain black crème polish.
I honestly feel like this
one impressed me the most,
because it was literally
pitch black in one coat.
The pigment on it is incredible,
and the formula is so smooth.
The prices do vary
depending on the formula,
but overall, the quality of
the polish is really good,
and I also love the brush
and handle on these bottles.
They make it super easy to paint my nails.
This is the Charlotte
Tilbury Take It All Off.
It's a biphase makeup remover,
and I had to Google what that meant,
because I had no idea.
It basically means you get
an oil and water in one,
and you have to shake the
product to combine it.
It specifically says this is
for eyes, lashes, and lips.
You have to shake it,
apply it to a cotton pad,
and soak the area for a few
seconds for an easy removal.
This honestly worked really well,
and I tried it on waterproof mascara,
which always takes me forever to remove.
I also have very sensitive eyes,
and this didn't irritate them at all.
I liked this, but I think
it's a little too pricey
for a makeup remover
you're only supposed to use
on your eyes and lips.-
Saie just drop these Lip Blurs.
They're matte lipsticks
that you can build up
to be super-full coverage
or dab on for a soft, blurred lip.
I used the shade Modern first
and just dabbed it on with my finger.
It gave this really
pretty soft wash of color.
This other one, in the shade
Classic, really shocked me
because it's so smooth and pigmented.
I was laughing because I
definitely went too far
over my lip line, but we move.
I would recommend a lip liner with these,
because the formula isn't
as matte as you'd expect
and it does move around a little.
Overall, I think these are nice
and feel good on the lips.
This is the KimChi Chic Beauty
Pearl Gone Wild pressed
shimmer highlighter.
This highlighter is so
stunning in the pan.
It's like this iridescent pearl color
that shifts to blue.
There's a lot of glitter in this,
which can look chunky or
make your skin look textured,
but this actually went on beautifully.
The glow it gives is unreal,
and that blue sparkle adds
a little something special.
It's not going to be for everyone,
especially if you hate glitter,
but this formula is so pretty,
and I really want more colors.
Patrick Ta released these Major Skin
crème foundation and
finishing powder duos.
I love the packaging on this,
especially this little flap
to protect the foundation from the powder.
I went in with my foundation brush first,
and, wow, this is full coverage,
and a little goes a long way.
I did my entire face with
just one dip into the pan.
I went over that with a sponge
to pick up excess product.
I wouldn't say the finish
is super skin-like.
It definitely looks and feels
like you're wearing foundation.
But for something this full coverage,
it doesn't look cakey to me.
It's also a more dewy
finish, which I think helps.
These are the Uoma Beauty
Black Magic Hypnotic Impact
high-shine lipsticks.
I am so into shiny lipstick
formulas these days.
Formula aside though, these
lipsticks are gorgeous.
The embossing, the glitter,
I could not stop staring at them.
They look just as beautiful on the lips.
This formula is literally a
lip gloss in lipstick form,
so you get the shine
and you get that moisturizing feeling.
The glitter is an overspray,
so they don't look glittery on the lips,
but I love these.
This is the Merit Bronze Balm,
and it's supposedly the
"easiest bronzer ever."
It's definitely the easiest bronzer
I think I've ever used.
It takes little to no
effort to blend this out,
and it didn't break up the
product I already had on.
I was worried the shade
I got was too light,
but I think it actually turned out OK.
It is buildable, I just wish
the color wasn't so sheer.
Other than that, I like this.
I'm seeing transfer-proof bullet lipsticks
pop up a lot more lately.
This one is the Nars Powermatte lipstick.
It has a really amazing color payoff.
This can definitely be
a one-swipe lipstick.
The texture is so unique.
The best way I can describe it is that it
kind of feels like the
Nars soft matte packaging
on its products, but on your lips.
It's this soft, powdery,
comfortable kind of matte
that felt really nice on the lips,
and it is transfer-proof,
so I highly recommend this.
This is the REM Beauty
Space Shape brow gel.
What really drew me in to this product
was the applicator.
I've never seen one like this before,
with a little doe foot on one side
and a comb on the other.
It was really easy to use,
and I like how it distributed the product.
The actual brow gel is nice.
It did what it had to do,
and it didn't leave my
brows feeling crunchy.
As much as I like the applicator, though,
I don't feel like the
formula is anything special.
KVD has reformulated its
iconic liquid lipstick,
so I picked up a few shades to try.
Just like everybody else,
I was very big into the
shade Lolita back in the day,
so I had to get Queen of
Poisons, which is its new name.
I'm gonna be honest.
I can't really tell much of a difference
between this formula and the old one.
I think it maybe feels a
little more lightweight,
but it still feels like I'm wearing
a slightly drying liquid lipstick.
I do really like the colors I got,
but this bright orange was pretty patchy.
I actually remember
having the same problem
with the brighter colors
in the old formula too,
so that's not great.
I also don't like this new packaging.
The wand is so weirdly long.
I don't know if you can tell,
but it was kind of hard to
control when I was applying.
I have been dying to try these Versed
Mood Lighting Luminizing
Glow Drops for a while.
People say that this is
another Flawless Filter dupe.
It does give a really
beautiful glow to the skin,
but there's not really any coverage to it,
so I wouldn't call this a dupe exactly.
It's like Flawless Filter's
more natural little sister.
It has a lot of great skincare ingredients
that made my skin feel
really nice and hydrated.
I actually preferred the
drops under my foundation
rather than on their own,
but I like these a lot.
This is a Face Sprinkles mini palette
from Designer Dust Co.
They have a lot of different
ones to choose from,
and you can even make a custom palette
with any of their glitters.
I was trying to show all of the colors,
but I couldn't lift it all the way
because one of the glitters
was completely liquefied.
Something weird happened
to it on its way to me,
but the rest of the
glitters were totally fine.
The glitter has a vegan
gel base that dries down.
You can apply it on the
face, hair, or body.
I was having fun just
putting it everywhere.
I loved all the colors,
and it was really easy to apply.
I'm not really into glitters,
but I think these worked great,
and this is one of the more affordable
glitter gel palettes I've seen.
This is the Summer
Fridays sheer skin tint.
It's supposed to be
lightweight, hydrating,
and very natural on the skin.
I definitely think it
is all of those things.
The coverage is obviously sheer,
but I was able to build it up no problem.
It evened out my skin nicely,
and it actually does feel weightless.
This would be a great
everyday skin tint for me.
I think for what it is and
how little product you get,
$42 is way too much.
But if you're looking
for a high-end skin tint,
this one is really nice.
I had been getting ads
for this Flower Knows
Strawberry Rococo collection for weeks,
and they definitely worked on me
because I bought three products.
First up, I tried the embossed blush.
The detail in the embossing is so cool.
I didn't even want to use it.
They do say that this is
meant to be a buildable blush,
but I think the color payoff
is a little too light.
It took me forever to get
the color payoff I wanted,
but it did look pretty in the end.
On to the eye-shadow palette.
The matte formula was soft and blendable,
but next time I would go
in with a primer first,
because it was slightly
patchy in some areas.
The glitter shade was incredible.
It was definitely the best
shade in the entire palette,
but it did give me some fallout.
Lastly, I tried the Cloud lip cream.
This is one of those mousse-y lip formulas
that has a velvety finish.
This felt really nice and
comfortable on the lips,
and I like the blurred effect it gives,
but I kind of wish it was the
same red as the packaging.
This is the Caliray So Blown clean primer.
It's one of those
dimethicone-y blurring primers
that makes your skin look matte.
I actually like how it made my skin look
without any foundation.
It feels nice and velvety,
and I definitely saw some blurring.
When I applied my foundation,
I realized I applied
too much of the primer,
so my skin actually
looked kind of textured
and the product pilled up a bit.
So the next time I tried it,
I went in with less and
focused on my oily areas,
and I still wasn't loving
how my foundation looked over this.
I just see way more
texture with this primer
than my normal primer.
I'll show them side by side,
so maybe you can kind of see what I mean.
I don't think that this is for me.
Milani released this
Conceal + Perfect line
with liquid under-eye brighteners,
contours, and highlighters.
These kind of feel like
a drugstore version
of the Charlotte Tilbury wands.
First, I tried the brightener
under my concealer.
I didn't notice much brightening at first,
but then I applied it with my fingertips
and got some better coverage.
Next, I tried the liquid contour.
This color does lean a little
bit red, which I don't love,
but it blended out really beautifully
and added a nice warmth to my face.
I applied the highlighter
next, and I loved this.
Again, it blends out really nicely,
and it doesn't add any texture to my skin.
It just gave a really pretty glow.
Even though I don't see
myself using the brightener,
I am a fan of these,
and I hope they expand the shade range.
These are the Kaleidos Epiphany Glow
Melt-On eyeliners.
They're all multichrome,
so they have these
really cool color shifts.
"Melt-On" was the perfect
description for these,
because they really do glide on so easily.
I've never had such a
smooth eyeliner application,
because they always
skip or they're too dry.
These are so easy to apply.
I thought that the tip would be too blunt
to create a wing, but I was actually
able to do it without any issue.
These are really beautiful,
and I highly recommend them.
I hope they expand the line
to include more everyday matte shades.
This is the Got2b Glued
for brows and edges.
For a long time, people have been using
Got2b hair gel as brow gel,
so they came out with this product
that's actually meant for brows.
I actually like how
this made my brows look.
It gives kind of a laminated brow effect,
nice and feathery,
but the gel itself left
a weird residue behind,
and it took forever to dry down.
Once it did dry, the brows
pretty much stayed in place,
but I've definitely
tried better brow gels.
This is one of the strangest new products
I've seen in a long time.
This is a Hipdot Eyecon
Baked Eye Pigment Shadow.
I got the Share Bear one.
These are essentially 3D figures
made of baked eye shadow.
They kind of feel like makeup Funko pops,
like more something you
collect rather than use.
But I used it.
The formula was actually pretty dry.
It took me a while to pick
up any product on my brush.
I definitely got a better application
and color payoff with my finger,
but still the formula was dry,
and I was tugging at my eyelid,
which I did not like.
This feels way more like a novelty
than an actual eye shadow.
Fenty released this Double Cheek'd Up
Freestyle Cream Blush Duo.
So you have this baby pink
color called Mali'booze
and this deeper medium
pink called Peony Droppa.
I've heard that the
Fenty cream blush formula
doesn't have the best color payoff,
but these were actually pigmented.
The problems for me
started with application.
I used a dense brush to apply first,
and it did lift my foundation,
so I tried my sponge, and
I think I made it worse.
My face was not powdered, by the way.
On the other side, I just used my fingers,
and that also lifted my
foundation, but way less.
I do really like these shades,
so I can see myself
using this on bare skin,
but I am not a fan of this formula
on top of foundation.
I finally got my hands on this
Fourth Ray Beauty Hunny Pot Lip Care Kit.
It keeps selling out, and now I know why.
This kit comes with a honey
lip scrub and a lip mask.
This packaging is literally so cute.
Look at this tiny honey dipper!
The scrub is like a regular sugar scrub.
It made my lips feel really soft,
but I wish it was a little more coarse
so I don't have to keep
dipping in for more.
This lip mask felt incredible.
It's thick and smooth
and really hydrating,
and it tastes sweet, which I liked.
This is the Tom Ford Soleil
Neige Lip Blush Lip Balm.
It's this transparent balm
with a bunch of platinum flecks in it.
It's actually one of those
color-changing products,
so once you apply it,
it turns into this deep pink shade.
"Lip blush" is a really
good way to describe it,
because it makes your lips look so rosy.
The actual balm formula is
really nice and hydrating,
but no one on planet Earth
needs a $58 lip balm.
This is cute, though.
Holo Taco polishes have been super popular
since they were released,
but I've actually never tried them.
I picked up a few different
formulas to test out.
I really did not like
the skinny brushes these came with,
but they actually sell
wide brush replacements,
so I just swapped them all out.
This cream shade I tried
first was so full-coverage
and applied really smoothly.
The color was just so rich.
I got this iridescent flaky topper,
and I was surprised at
how much I liked it.
I don't really do toppers, but this one
looks so shifty and cool on the nails.
I obviously had to test out
some holographic polishes.
Both of these also applied really well
and had amazing color payoff.
I had to turn my flashlight on
so you could really see the holo.
I applied the Super Glossy Topcoat
on all of these formulas,
and I really loved it.
I like it when my topcoat
has an almost plumping effect,
where it makes regular
polish kind of look like gel,
and this did that while making
the manicure super shiny.
Overall, I'm really happy
with all the shades I got,
and I can't wait to try more.
This is the Milani Daze
of Disco Shimmer Spray.
It's supposed to be a holographic
glitter setting spray,
but I was seeing absolutely no glitter
when I sprayed some on my hand.
And I shook this really
well, like for a full minute.
I sprayed it all over my face,
and it did make my skin
look extremely dewy,
but I still wasn't really
seeing the glitter effect.
I could only see if I was looking
really, really, really closely.
The glitter effect is
definitely not as noticeable
as I thought it was going to be,
and the actual setting-spray formula
just made me look oily.
This month, I tested out a lot of products
from Simihaze Beauty.
This is a new brand for me,
so let's start with the stuff I liked.
The Solar Tint blush duo comes with
a cheek pigment and a cheek gloss.
These both went on really easily,
and the pigment is so good.
Surprisingly, I loved
the cheek gloss more,
even though it's not super
practical for all-day wear.
I didn't love the color
of this Velvet Blur
matte lip balm on my skin tone,
but the formula itself was so good.
It has the comfort of a lip balm
but the pigment and blurring
effect of a matte lipstick.
It's creamy and super comfortable.
I thought the Lunar lip gel
and the Super Slick mini
lip balm were just OK.
The lip gel was pretty,
but the formula was nothing special.
It's just a thin lip gloss.
The mini lip balm was pretty moisturizing,
and the tint is cute,
but it's so little
product for what you pay.
Again, nothing special.
Now for the products I just didn't like.
I wanted to love the Sun
Flush all-over face tint,
but it just ended up being really patchy
and broke up my foundation.
And I tried this a few different ways
to see if I was just applying it wrong,
but it still messed up
my foundation underneath.
The Easy Lash Clean Lift mascara
just didn't do much for my lashes.
I didn't get much lift,
I got little to no volume,
and my lashes weren't
lengthened very much.
Overall, I love the
packaging of this brand,
and it does have some standout products,
but I think it's all very overpriced
for how the actual formulas perform.
Everyone has been raving
about the Summer Fridays Lip Butter Balms.
This set with the minis
is limited-edition,
but they sell all of
these shades in full size.
I ended up really enjoying these.
The formula is on the thicker side,
but not sticky.
They feel really moisturizing,
and I like how they give
an almost lip-gloss effect.
I loved all of the tinted balms,
but I think Poppy was my favorite.
They all give a pretty,
subtle wash of color,
and they have this nice vanilla scent
that's not overpowering.
I'm obsessed with these.
This is the Danessa Myricks Beauty
Lightwork IV Transcendence palette.
I'm not gonna lie,
I was very intimidated
by this palette at first.
It has four different formulas:
velvet chromes, which are
color-shifting powders;
pressed chrome flakes,
which are flaky toppers;
glass metallics, which are
super-reflective powders;
and aqua chromes, which
are water-activated
duo-chrome pigments.
So there is a lot going on.
I started applying over a light wash
of black eye-shadow base to
make the colors pop more,
but I don't even think
I needed to do that,
because these powders are so pigmented.
I was determined to use all
of the different formulas,
so I added one of the
metallics in the inner corners
and put the chrome flakes in the center.
The flakes were the only formula
that was a little difficult to work with,
only because they're kind of
hard to pick up and apply,
but I think they added
a really cool texture
and color shift to the eye look.
I used an aqua chrome for some eyeliner,
and it's so reflective and sparkly,
and it dried down quickly.
This palette is extremely pricey,
and I did get some slight fallout,
but the quality is definitely there,
and I think it's so much
more versatile than it seems.
The shades in here are so transformative
and really inspire you
to play with your makeup.
Plus, it can also be used on the face.
These are the L'Oréal Colour Riche
Intense Volume matte lipsticks.
I thought these were going to be similar
to the Nars Powermatte
lipstick I tried a while ago,
but the formula is different.
The color payoff on these is so good,
and they apply really smoothly.
This is one of the most
comfortable matte formulas
I've ever tried, especially
from the drugstore.
What makes this lipstick
different from the Nars one
is that it's unfortunately
not transfer-proof.
To be fair, it claims to be smudge-proof,
so it's not the same thing.
Regardless, I think these lipsticks
are comfortable on the lips,
and the colors are so rich,
so I really like them.
Apparently Gwen Stefani
has her own beauty brand
called GXVE, and this is
the first product from it
that I've ever tried.
This is the Double Dippin'
2-1 lip color remover
and hydrating lip mask.
I wanted to test it out with
my Nars Powermatte lipstick,
since it's one of my
hardest-to-remove lipsticks.
The formula of this lip mask feels
like a makeup-removing cleansing balm.
If you've never tried one,
they feel really oily.
Because of that, it actually
broke the lipstick down really well.
It made it super easy to remove.
However, as a regular
lip mask, it just feels
way too oily and thin to be comfortable.
This just feels like one of those products
that they market as multiuse
to make it sound more innovative.
Lights Lacquer just released
its winter collection,
called Cocktail Hour.
I do own a lot of their polishes,
so this isn't a new brand for me,
but I definitely think this is my favorite
color story they've ever done.
The polishes have those wide, flat brushes
I love for applying.
It just makes it so
much easier and faster.
I tried the cream shades,
Old Money and Audrey, first,
and both were full coverage in two coats,
and the application was really smooth.
Then I tried the jelly
shade, called Lady in Red.
Because this is a jelly,
it's way more sheer than a cream,
so I ended up doing two thicker coats
for full color payoff.
The color is slightly lighter on my nails
than in the bottle, but
still pretty and so shiny.
Next I tried To the Nines,
which is a metallic polish.
I really love this color,
but this formula is
probably the least forgiving
when it comes to streaks and bubbles.
My two absolute favorite
shades from the collection
are Whiskey Neat and Diamonds Are Forever.
Whiskey Neat is also a metallic formula,
but it's more of a duo-chrome,
and Diamonds Are Forever
is like a milky taupe
with a bunch of superfine glitter in it.
I don't think these colors
separately are anything new,
but I love how they all work
together in this collection,
and the formulas are all so good.
We have yet another
color-changing product to review.
This is the Kylie Cosmetics
transformative liquid lip tint
that was a part of her
collab with the Wizard of Oz.
It goes from emerald green to pink.
The smell is interesting.
It kind of smells like an apple-y shampoo.
The formula is pretty thin.
I do like this giant doe-foot applicator.
The color is actually a little more unique
than other color-changing
lip products I've tried.
The pink was a bit deeper and I think
more flattering on my skin tone.
I would wear this again because
the stain it leaves behind is pretty,
but I do wish the formula was thicker.
These are the Fleeky Friday Cosmetics
Crystal Crease eyeliners.
These are handmade
reusable crystal eyeliners
that you apply with lash glue.
It was a little hard for me
to get them in a comfortable spot,
because I have hooded lids.
You can cut these to fit
your eye shape better,
so I'm going to do that next time,
but I think these are so fun.
They look like you just did so much work
applying each individual rhinestone.
Cirque Colors is one of my
favorite nail-polish brands,
and they just dropped
their holiday collection.
I love that they have a spin
on the classic red and green,
this mix of pearly shades,
and then this more unique duochrome.
Sashay reminds me of red
bows and Christmas ornaments.
To me it leans more pink than red,
but it's still beautiful.
Verdigris Jelly is a jelly polish.
It is more sheer because it's a jelly,
so I did three layers,
and it looked so shiny.
My favorite shade in the collection
is definitely Tahitian Pearl,
which is this dark duochrome
that shifts from pink to green,
and it has this holographic glitter in it.
I did three coats for this one too
because it showed the color shift better,
and I think it made the glitter pop more.
This is a really unique color,
and I can see myself wearing it a lot.
The last three shades are all
a pearlescent, sheer white
with different-colored shimmers.
Serenity has a green shimmer,
Soleil has a pinky-red shimmer,
and Siren has a purple shimmer.
These are all really pretty,
but you definitely don't need all of them,
because they're so similar.
This entire collection
applied really smoothly,
and even though some shades
had to be layered up,
I was happy with how they all turned out.
This is the Half Magic
Magic Flik liquid eyeliner.
It has this really interesting
tip that's paddle-shaped
so you can draw fine lines with the edge
and then fill in with the wide side.
I suck at eyeliner, but this shape
actually really helped
me draw the wing easily.
I will say that I think
the actual eyeliner formula
is not the best.
The black isn't super
pigmented like I would prefer,
but I really liked this tip shape.
This is the KVD Dazzle
Long-Wear Eyeshadow Stick.
It's supposed to be a
one-and-done-type product,
so you don't need primer.
You just swipe it on and blend.
I was really surprised at
how soft this formula is.
It's actually a little too soft,
like, you have to be gentle with it,
but it really does glide on easily.
This is packed with glitter and shimmer,
and it just looks so pretty on the eyes.
It's like a way to do glitter
without any of the mess. I'm a fan.
I tried a couple products from
the K-beauty brand Romand.
This glitter palette has been raved about,
so I was really excited to play with it.
The shades are meant to be on the softer,
more translucent side,
so you can layer them over eye shadow.
I just applied some of
my blush on the eyes
and then applied a few
of the shades on top.
There are shimmer formulas,
fine glitters, and more chunky glitters.
Overall, I would say the
formulas are on the dry side,
but they were actually
pretty easy to work with.
I had no problem swiping
or patting them on,
and I had little to no glitter fallout.
I also tried the Glasting Water Tint.
The color and gloss are separate layers,
so you get that long-lasting
tint with a glossy finish.
These feel so hydrating and
comfortable on the lips.
They're really lightweight,
and they definitely do leave a stain.
Look at my hand after I
wiped those swatches off.
I've never tried a product
from Jane Iredale before,
but this one intrigued me.
This is the HydroPure tinted serum.
It's a serum with a bunch
of pigment beads inside
that are meant to give you light coverage.
You're supposed to mix this
with your fingers first
to break up the beads,
then apply with your fingers.
I really don't like finger
applications for foundations,
but it really was the best
way to apply this product.
It did not look great
when I tried it with
a brush and my sponge.
The coverage is definitely light.
I feel like it looked like
I had no makeup on at all.
I was hoping it would feel moisturizing,
but it felt like nothing on my skin.
All my other makeup went
on top of this just fine,
and I really liked how
my skin was looking.
It's so expensive, but
I think this is great
for people who want a very
natural-looking skin tint.
Charlotte Tilbury released
these Hypnotising Pop Shot single shadows.
The packaging on this is so cute.
This is meant to be a
super-glittery, pigmented,
multidimensional shadow.
This was really easy to apply.
I just swiped it on with my finger
and blended out the edges.
I did get a tiny bit of fallout,
but I was able to just brush it away.
I really love the sparkly,
shifty effect you get with this formula.
You can definitely get a similar effect
with one of those ColourPop
Super Shock shadows,
but this formula is really
beautiful on the eyes.
Rare Beauty just released a powder version
of its super-popular highlighters.
I've been seeing some
conflicting statements
about whether this product looks glittery.
There is definitely some
superfine glitter in this formula,
but I don't think it looks
glittery on the skin.
The glow is obviously
there, and it's so pretty.
It's almost wet-looking.
I actually thought it
emphasized my texture a bit
when I first tried it.
When I tried it the second time,
I just went in with a little less product,
and it looked better.
I don't think this is as natural-looking
as the liquid version,
but it's still a really nice highlighter.
I tried a couple new
Fenty products this month:
the Plush Puddin'
Intensive Recovery lip mask
and the Glossy Posse Volume 5.0.
Let's talk about the lip mask first.
The packaging is really cool.
You twist it and the product
dispenses from the top,
so you don't have to dip into it.
The formula is very thick,
which I personally love.
It just feels so moisturizing
and plush on the lips.
It also gave this really nice
shine I wasn't expecting.
I did wear this lip
mask for a couple nights
to see if it helped with my dryness,
and I saw the difference.
My lips were so much
more soft and hydrated,
so I am definitely going
to keep using this.
Now on to the Glossy Posse Volume 5.0.
Fenty Beauty does these gloss sets
for the holiday season every year,
usually with a
limited-edition shade inside.
This set contains a gloss
bomb cream in Cupcakin',
a gloss bomb heat in Fenty Glow Heat,
and a regular gloss bomb in Fuchsia Flex.
Cupcakin' is a really pigmented gloss,
and Fenty Glow Heat gives
you that kind of spicy,
tingly lip plumping.
Fuchsia Flex is the specific
shade that's been going viral.
It's Fenty's regular gloss formula
in this really beautiful deep pink
that has a ton of glitter in it.
All of these formulas
feel so good on the lips.
Fenty does not miss
with its gloss formula.
People have been raving about
the Kosas Revealer Concealer forever,
so I finally got it.
It's supposed to be medium
coverage and super creamy.
This concealer was easy to work with
and blended out so quickly and easily.
The coverage looked a bit
lighter than medium to me,
but it covered enough.
I would go in with a
little more next time,
but I loved how this looked.
I also got the Cloud Set setting powder,
which people also really love.
I used my puff to apply this,
and it smoothed everything
out almost instantly.
I was so impressed by this powder,
and I usually hate pressed powders.
I never use them, let
alone to set my concealer,
but this looked so nice.
I used it on the rest of my face too,
and it just gave this
really soft, blurred look.
It mattified, but not too much.
I loved these two products,
especially together.
This is the Hourglass Cosmetics
Phantom Volumizing glossy balm.
It's supposed to be a
lip balm, lip plumper,
and a lip gloss all in one product.
These applied nicely,
but because this formula is so fragile,
it's easy to apply too much.
I had to smooth the product out
with my finger a couple times,
but other than that, I loved these.
They have this really nice cooling effect.
They do feel like a
super-moisturizing lip balm,
and they have this high-shine
finish, like a gloss.
It didn't do much for
me in terms of plumping,
so I think if that's the main thing
you want from a lip
product, don't get this one.
I did a little haul at ELF,
and I got some new products
and some products I've
been wanting to try.
First up is this ELF
luminous putty bronzer.
This goes from a putty
formula to a powder.
Up close, you can see a
lot of shimmer in this,
but it doesn't look that way on the skin.
This is one of the most blendable
bronzers I've ever tried.
Like, it takes no time
at all to blend this out,
and it brings a really
natural warmth to the skin.
This was so good.
Next, I tried the Halo Glow powder puff,
which is always out of stock.
People love this.
I thought it wasn't
going to be any different
to my normal powder puffs, but it is.
It's much thicker and softer
than these cheap ones I buy.
It does pick up a lot of product,
but I just evened it out
on the back of my hand.
This did such a nice job
of applying my powder.
Next, I tried the Lash 'N Roll mascara,
which kind of reminds me
of the Benefit Roller Lash.
I usually hate silicone-brush mascaras,
but I actually like how this
one applied the product.
It felt like it got every single lash.
My lashes are so straight, but
this gave them a nice curl.
I wish it thickened my
lashes more, but for 6 bucks,
this is a really good drugstore mascara.
The last product I tested
was the glossy lip stain.
I can't believe I've
never tried these before.
This formula is so interesting.
It feels like water on the lips.
Like, hydrating but also weightless.
These are a bit patchy.
There were some areas where it looked
like the product wasn't sticking.
After letting the product
sit for a few minutes,
I removed it, and it definitely
did leave a stain behind,
but the stain also looked patchy.
I do like how this
formula feels on the lips,
but it doesn't apply evenly.
For the most part, though,
this was a pretty good haul.